kyrie irving uh who plays for the
cavaliers he he recently said that he
believes the world is flat
is that a subject that you covered with
him did you are you aware of that i
wouldn't even know how to broach that
topic
word is that what you think what do you
say
i don't know i guess maybe just kind of
i guess if you don't you feel it it
won't really make any kind of a
difference i don't i don't understand
the philosophy behind the flat earth
theory why why do you say that i just
don't understand first of all what
differences make
could be flat could not be flat there
could only be there could be 12
continents how would you know
that's a matter of how we draw it up but
i feel like with the world with the
earth when you stand back and you look
at the horizon you can see curvature you
can actually see it unlike a dinosaur or
something yeah or if you fly in one
direction you'll come back around which
is which in a flat world probably would
not happen that is true that is true but
these guys don't go around they go to
cleveland and then they go to
and then maybe that they need longer
trips i think is probably what every
everybody that's into flat earth
it was very hard for them to get into it
in a minute it took like a year and a
half for them to admit it well first it
was just black dudes basically i feel
like they were into it at first
yeah
i was violently opposed to it but the
one thing about flat earth you punch in
flat earth on youtube you're going to
get all the debunking
like why is there so many people working
against it it's crazy it's a it's it's
they're doing the exact same thing the
flat earth that they do to 911 jfk iran
contra they got people producing
debunking videos like why are you doing
that if it's so small it's not it's
you should ask yourself why is there a
debate about it how is there a debate
still in this time with the internet why
are people and people are there's so
many people that are afraid to admit
that they're looking into flat earth
because the amount of ridicule you get
you know what i mean i was i was quiet
about it but i was against it i was
trying to uh you know people kept coming
up to have you have you looked in the
flat earth i'm like dude shut the [ __ ]
up yeah you're crazy it's like a couple
years ago
[ __ ] joe i was on joe's podcast and he
would bring him because people are so
dumb there's some people out there still
believe the earth is flat and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are they really there's
people like that and this was just a few
years ago and now here you and now
you're yeah then i kept trying to debunk
it like i would get in arguments with
people and that's the typical story
everyone's trying to debunk it the one
thing that made me realize something was
wrong is i always believed that the moon
the moon landings were faked and that's
what i thought nasa was i thought nasa
was in charge of the moon missions i
didn't think they were in charge of all
space information i thought there was
all these scientists everywhere and
they're they're figuring out you know
[ __ ] about the universe
and now um once i once once i i i
was looking into it and i realized oh
[ __ ] all these pictures of earth from
space they're all cgi composites and
nasa admits it they go you know what we
take the images and all the we take this
information strips and then we get an
artist to put together i'm like wait a
minute you guys aren't even getting real
pictures of the [ __ ] earth from space
i go i had the picture where's the
bootlegs yep where's the [ __ ] space
bootlegs and you get that you get the
earth on your iphone that's the default
the default picture i got i had looked
at earth every day on my iphone i see
that go how are you going to tell me the
earth's flat i see so the guy said go
because i got i got a master's in
engineering look into it and so i did
and i realized damn then i started
tracing these pictures back back to nasa
then i realized wait a minute nasa
nasa is controlling all our space
information
i go nasa does that i thought they just
did the moon in the space shuttle yeah
and nasa's gutter dude they've been
around for 60 years they've been to the
moon allegedly four times now six times
six months yes six times and then they
destroyed all the technology come on man
dude that's the worst if that was a
business you'd be like this is that
you know what they had to say they
destroyed it what are they going to say
yeah what else are they going to say
they're going to let people
they destroyed all the video the raw
video footage the raw audio footage all
the telemetry data which tracked where
they were in space oh that's gone
[Music]
all right we got uh
all right now let's here we go some more
panicked emails all right from a real
flat earther i love this guy staying on
the subject
billy boy the thing is there is no space
that's what people mean by nasa st
stealing money
s-t-e-e-l-i-n-g
stealing money the sun and the moon
are inside
the firmament
dude this is [ __ ] amazing
i gotta look this up what the [ __ ] is
affirmative you know what you know what
i love about this [ __ ] this flatter
first stuff that was the first time i
just went eight straight seconds without
thinking about the pandemic
people do yourself a favor get a flat
earther in your [ __ ] life
okay firmament the heavens or the sky
especially when regarded as a
tangible thing
oh god i i need to know all about the
firmament okay
in biblical
cosmology
i didn't know they did facials back then
sorry
biblical cosmology is the biblical
writer's conception of the cosmos as
organized structured
entity including its origin order
meaning and destiny oh back when they
were writing the bible
okay
all right
where are we in the biblical cosmology
the firmament is the vast solid dome
created by god
on the second day to divide the primal
sea called
te home
to home
into upper and lower portions so that
the dry land could appear
then god said
oh my god i'm going to start quoting
scripture during a pandemic on my
podcast this is really going to freak
people out i'm just reading firmament
on wikipedia you can follow along and
then god said
let there be a firmament in the midst of
the waters
and let it divide the waters
from the waters
it doesn't make sense this is why i
don't go to church how do you divide the
waters from the waters
um
thus god made the firmament
and the divided and divided the waters
which were under the firmament do you
mean the land i thought this guy's
talking about the sky
from the waters which were above the
firmament and so it was
sorry i actually accidentally shut off
the recorder or so it was
and it was so sorry and god called the
firmament heaven
so the
evening and the morning
were the second day i mean if anybody
can tell me what the [ __ ] i just read
god said let me let there be firmament
in the midst of the waters and let's let
it divide
the waters from the waters thus god made
the firmament and of i don't know what
it is
the word firmament is recorded in middle
english narrative based on scripture
dated 12 50. it appeared in the kim
james bible
the word firmament is used to translate
a word in biblical hebrew
what the [ __ ] meaning to beat or spread
out thinly the process of making a dish
by hammering thin a lump of metal
like most ancient people the hebrews
believed the sky was a solid dome
with the sun moon planets and stars
embedded in it okay now i know what it
is the hebrews regarded the earth as a
plane or a hill
figured like a hemisphere that makes god
a lot scarier like he's right there
uh
swimming on water
okay the earth was a plane or a hill
figured like a hemisphere swimming on
water
over this is an arch
arch to solid vault of heaven
to this vault are fastened the lights
the stars
so slight is the elevation that birds
may rise to it and fly along its expanse
that's fascinating that's a whole
different way of looking at the world
all right
okay there is no space it does not exist
there is a dome over the earth basically
a force field people believe this is the
firmament from the bible
now you were caught up on the motive
and i understand this
but you can't deny the facts based on
not knowing the motive
i i did you just prove something there
i i i think i need to eat some corned
beef or something i can't i can't even
think today a detective doesn't walk
into a room see a dead guy on the floor
who was shot in the head with no gun in
the room and say well nobody had motive
motive to kill this guy
so he's not dead and nobody did
um i could go right back you with that
analogy
uh
a
detective doesn't walk in on a murder
case that was already solved and then
try to resolve it
huh there's my gumshoe [ __ ] metaphor
how do you like that one
all right no the fact is he was murdered
so now try to figure out the motive
this is what people did
at first they thought it was flat
evidently and that there was a firmament
that you could you know if you could
tall enough you could reach up if you're
a bird you could fly into it and then
people like oh no wait a second
wait a second
um
well how do you explain like telescopes
and [ __ ]
seeing all of this stuff
are they just misinterpreting other
galaxies
and black holes and all of that or is
that all just [ __ ]
because i'm gonna be honest with you i i
will agree with you on this thing
i don't know if jupiter is out there
i've never seen it
i've just been told that it's there
okay so i'm not going to wag my finger
at you that way but i mean i'm kind of
going out on a limb here that you know
trying to get everybody on the same page
around the world with the same lie
you know
to finance nasa
why does vietnam give a [ __ ] about nasa
making money
are they getting a cut man all right
money is the only is only a small part
of this description there's a much
bigger and more important reason for it
oh here we go i can drop the bomb on you
but you probably wouldn't believe it
anyway so i won't oh come on don't don't
take your bomb and go home
now bill oh i'm getting a lecture here
there has never been an experiment done
to this day to prove that the earth has
a curvature or is moving that is a 100
fact
okay
dude you're really [ __ ] with
everything that i've been told
um because i gotta be honest with you uh
in defense of what you're saying i never
looked up
whether there's ever been an experiment
i thought when they got in boats and
they sailed that away and came back
around the other way they were like well
goddamn
this motherfucker's rap
uh that should be a major red flag for
you
i just love how you assume that just
because you now say this that you just
proved something to me send me a link
send me evidence to back up what you're
saying other than that this is just
crazy talk
anyway it's a theory
which is a fine
which is fine theories are good but if
you point out that this stuff is just a
theory and was never proven people get
pissed at you
well it's what's
okay well then where is where is the
study that proved what you're saying is
true
okay why isn't there a link to that
maybe he gets to it as smart as we are
today and if the earth really was a
globe
there would be a thousand ways to prove
it
uh have you ever flown around the world
because i have
all right
what did the pilot do did he just subtly
just sort of like
suddenly go to the right
[Laughter]
to fly all the way back the long way we
didn't run out of jet fuel and we didn't
have to refuel video isn't
evidence because it can be faked
in the same way that bigfooter loch ness
monster videos aren't proof of them
nasa and space videos aren't proof of
space i believe in the scientific method
observable testable repeatable all right
well then let's do this with your theory
there are many ways to okay here we go
there are many ways to prove the earth
is flat and stationary water always
finds its level
meaning the top of still water is always
flat no matter what scale
they use
to
use water as a leveling tool before
lasers
as earth is 80 water there are many
cities mountains lighthouses etc that
can be seen
way farther than i thought it was
gravity i i don't i don't understand i
don't get any of this i mean i'd be
honest with you i don't i don't know why
water's leveled this is beyond
my pay grade
i don't think about this [ __ ]
all right
um but videos can be faked and then
videos can also
give evidence
you know
if i showed you a video of a dead body
you wouldn't believe that the guy was
dead i like when you do you think world
war ii didn't happen
because you're not there to witness it
you can't touch it you can't test it
it never happened
because all there is now is just movies
of it so does that mean that didn't
happen you can't believe it because it's
fake
because it can be faked
i know
i this is this is when i just wish i had
some sort of scientific background
because then i could tell this guy is
actually 100 percent right
and that
or
what i think is right is what i've been
told i don't [ __ ] know
and earth is 80 water there are many
cities mountains lighthouses etc that
can be seen way farther than
would be possible on a globe with
dimensions they give us i 100 disagree
with that
100 [ __ ] disagree with that
um
that that is the first thing that i can
100 disagree with
uh so the earth is either flat or
astronomically bigger than they say it
is the north star
does not move
in the sky ever
this proves we are not moving what about
everything else that is moving
everything else rotates around that
something is moving
this proves we are not the north star
they picked that out because it's at the
[ __ ] epicenter i think of the where
we're lined up and that's how you use to
guide yourself by the stars in the
northern hemisphere
let me ask you this sir do you sail or
ma'am do you sail do you know how to
[ __ ]
um anyway there are many ways to book a
i i just i
am i supposed to keep reading this
what about the rest of it that turns
so what does the sun do
this is fascinating
where does the sun go when it goes down
is that god just putting on a dimmer
huh does he move it across the sky
who's moving we're not moving
what is moving
um
so the earth is either flat or
astronomic than stated the north star
does not move in the sky ever this
proves we are not moving because the
earth is supposedly
supposedly moves
an astronomical distance around the sun
each year and tilts on its axis each
year also so this would be impossible
gravity does not exist
this is just a theory that it was never
proven
am i being trolled here in a stupid one
that makes no sense at that gravity
supposedly holds down
skyscrapers and boulders and stones that
weigh hundreds of tons
but can't hold down a blackbird or a
fruit fly or butterfly how does that
makes oh my god
and this is where i tap up